bonjour riadh sidaoui merci de répondre
à nos questions sur arte france le
groupe d'experts de loi nul sur le yémen
victime d'espionnage étatique numérique
qu'est-ce que ça traduit
se traduire un gros scandale surtout
pour le monde musulman et l'islam à ce
que l'arabie saoudite se présente comme
la gardienne des lieux saints de la
mecque et de médine il veut pas affiché
publiquement ses relations avec israël
mais israël de voile toujours si
relations rappelant le 22 novembre 2007
binyamin netanyahou avec le directeur du
mossad je sais qu ils ont rencontré
mohammed bin hamman le prince héritier a
là un niveau minimum c'est le site
touristique saoudien mais dès samedi ne
veut pas afficher cette relation or il
ya eu toujours là mais l'alliance
objective entre israël et la mise hommes
qu'ils étaient presque souvent dans le
même camp contre nasser et l'egypte les
années 60 contre saddam hussein en 1991
contre aujourd'hui contre l'iran donc
quand on dit les rangs les
roussillonnais et le hezbollah aux les
bons donc c'est un grand scandale parce
que les saoudiens en tutelle des
pèlerinages ils sont les gardiens des
lieux c'est la mecque et la midi et en
même temps des v nations présentes en
est avec les services secrets israéliens
parce qu'on ne peut pas avoir ce
logiciel pegasus sans le feu vert
évidemment les roussettes est née sol à
la maison mère de pegasus semble vouloir
envoyer les pistes réaction est ambigu
puisque le groupe confirme que kamel
jendoubi n'a pas été visé par l'un de
leurs clients actuels on rappelle que la
faire remontrer à 2019 et on sait que
l'arabie saoudite a été exclu de la
liste des clubs pegasus depuis le 25
novembre dernier votre réaction
je connais personnellement monsieur
kamel jendoubi c'est un mail éton que
d'abord un militant des droits de
l'homme un homme courageux et intègres
et n'est pas vendable et les pages table
et là il a organisé les élections en
tunisie après la révolution il a une
réputation internationale d'être
courageuse intègre et être espionnés par
les sorguais ça me tente pas parce que
moi j'ai suivi ces déclarations dans
certaines télévisions langue arabe et
les très critique vis-à-vis de la
situation des droits de l'homme et des
crimes commis par les saoudiens contre
la population civile yéménite inc c'est
la revanche donc on ne vise 7 c'est
compréhensible mais comme je dis là les
scandales c'est pour le monde musulman
et les saoudiens qui se présente
toujours comme un pays en israël mais en
réalité aussi bien que les relations
sont très très étroite historiquement
est aujourd'hui également
quel impact pour le groupe est né somme
et plus généralement pour pour israël
puisque vous avez dit pour avoir payé en
sus faut avoir l'aval du gouvernement
israélien le groupe israélien a assuré
que le logiciel espion et est uniquement
utilisée pour lutter contre la
criminalité et contre le terrorisme
non pas du tout c'était comme un échange
du service des marocains ils ont demandé
le logiciel ont tenu pour viser 6 mieux
téléphone algérie et à titre d'exemple
dons qui seront utilisés la
normalisation avec israël les bonnes
relations avec israël donc obtenir au
bugue asus contre qui contre 6000
téléphone algeria la même chose qu'on a
remis samedi ils ont sollicité ce
programme afin de l'utiliser contre elle
ne les relie au yémen contre contre les
activistes au yémen et surtout aussi au
liban c'est qu'il ya pas mal de coeur
olibeau donc il ya une chance et un
échange d'intérêts dans ce monde et
d'espionnage et donnerons évidemment
l'arabie saoudite a su tenir la
normalisation de bari qui est un pays
très très lié à l'arabie saoudite avec
israël la même chose vis-à-vis des
émirats arabes unis la marcheuse
vis-à-vis du maroc reste 6 très sensible
pour la famille royale parce que la
famille royale
saoudite est divisée le prince mohammed
sale mais la jeune génération élevée des
relations publiques affiché publiquement
entre de guinée n'a pas honte d'avoir
des relations avec israël or la vieille
garde qui entoure son père sa mère
disait mais non mais non ce qu'on peut
pas franchir cette étape on peut pas
signer ligne rouge pour nous que les
relations restent discrètes mais pas
public parce que nous sommes les
gardiens de l'us les lieux saints de la
mecque 2010 et on a le titre de
pèlerinage
donc on peut pas faire cette aventure
restons discrets mais malheureusement
les rails est dévoilent souvent ces
rencontres comme été le cas le 22
novembre 2007 vous avez beaucoup évoqué
ce scandale donc pour l'arabie saoudite
mais pour israël vous n'avez pas répondu
à ma question quel impact pour pour
israël et en terme d'image notamment
non elle voudrait lui cherche pas ne
cherche pas pour israël à arrêter comme
d'amener plusieurs fois vous indiquons
sécurité à l'assemblée nationale dans
les deux relais dans les agressions de
droits de l'homme non pour israël le
corps israël c'est toujours les intérêts
qui compte ce sont des pays qui sortent
pour normaliser leurs relations avec
elle parce qu'en principe le monde arabe
doit être uni en abonnés en faveur de la
cause palestinienne
donc si on voit des états qui laisse la
cause palestinienne est établi de bonnes
relations donc c'est l'intérêt de l'état
à l'intérieur d'états je pense pas qu
israël cherche vraiment avoir une très
belle image dans le monde vu donc
qu'elle a un passé lourd que ce soit à
l'onu au sein des organisations des
droits de l'homme
merci riadh sidaoui d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
expert du monde arabe les vous êtes le
directeur du centre arabe de recherche
et d'analysé politique et social à
genève